-As the president
continues to lie
about the coronavirus outbreak,
we are now seeing
what it's like
when a lifelong scam artist
is in charge of responding
to a public health crisis.
For more on this,
it's time for a closer look.
[ Cheers and applause ]
When it comes to his presidency,
there's nothing Donald Trump
cares about more
than the stock market.
He brags about it virtually
every chance he gets,
and on Friday, during a visit
to CDC headquarters in Atlanta,
Trump predicted
that the coronavirus outbreak,
which has now hit more than
100,000 cases worldwide
and over 500 here in the U.S.,
would actually be good
for the economy.
-Could you just address the
economic piece, though,
because there's obviously a lot
of fear about the coronavirus?
-I mean it is a fact.
You know, if you don't want
to think about me,
I like when people happen
to stay in the United States
and spend their money
in the United States, okay?
So, I think people are staying
in the United States,
they're going to spend their
money in the United States.
-That's right,
Trump thinks coronavirus
will help the economy
because people will
spend money here in the U.S.
[ As Trump ] In fact, I've been
buying toilet paper at Costco
that I'm going to resell
at a profit if things get worse.
There you go.
The president said on Friday
that coronavirus would actually
be good for the economy.
Let's see
how the stock market did
when it opened
on Monday morning.
-We're coming on the air
with breaking news.
This is
the New York Stock Exchange.
The trading day is just
beginning on Wall Street.
And there are fears that the Dow
will drop and drop quickly,
and we're already seeing that.
The Dow industrials are off
right now 17 points or 6.5%,
you've got the NASDAQ off 5.8%,
and then the S&P down 6 1/3%.
-At this point, I've never seen
this much anxiety
on the floor of
the New York Stock Exchange.
There are traders
running everywhere.
We are watching these levels.
-Has trading now stopped?
Has it hit that 7% figure?
-Trading has stopped because
we've seen a drop of 7%,
which means trading will stop
for the next 15 minutes.
-[ As Trump ] I'm selling this
toilet paper for $1,000 a sheet!
[ Laughter, applause ]
[ Normal voice ]
That's right. Three days.
Three days after Trump predicted
coronavirus would be good
for the economy,
the stock market plunged
so much, when it opened,
the trading had to be stopped.
The drop was so bad,
the red arrow on the TV screen
grew legs and ran away.
Now, the selloff wasn't due
entirely to coronavirus.
It was also due in large part
to a war over oil prices
launched by Saudi Arabia.
Still, a lot of people
are understandably worried.
And while there's
no the reason to panic,
governments across the world are
taking extreme measures
to mitigate the outbreak.
Over the weekend, Italy put
millions of people on lockdown
in regions hit hardest
by the outbreak
where people were rushing
to catch the last trains
leaving Milan before
the lockdown took effect.
-Officials in Italy putting
16 million people on lockdown.
Now, that's a quarter
of the country's population.
Video shows people rushing
to catch the last train
as they left northern Italy.
-This is what Italians look like
when they're rushing.
[ Laughter ]
I mean, obviously, in Italy,
to run for a train is
a fate worse than death.
I'm shocked they didn't have
cigarettes in one hand
and Aperol spritzers
in the other.
I mean, if you've ever
been to Italy,
you know that, for Italians,
what you just saw there
is DEFCON one.
I mean, in Italy, stores
just close in the afternoon
so people can nap,
and planes just take off
whenever they want.
At the Rome airport,
most departure times say,
"It leaves when it leaves,
capiche?"
And here in the U.S., New York,
the state with the most cases,
is currently taking
its own precautions
to deal with the coronavirus.
Governor Andrew Cuomo declared
a state of emergency
as the number of cases rises
to over 100
with thousands more being asked
to self-quarantine.
And on Sunday,
Cuomo offered this advice
to New Yorkers taking
the subway.
-If you can move to a train car
that is not as dense,
if you see a packed train car,
let it go by.
Wait for the next train.
-I'm sorry, did you think
people were picking crowded cars
on purpose?
Every train car is packed.
[ Cheers and applause ]
"Excuse me. I'm sorry.
Where are the less-dense
train cars?"
That's why
those showtime subway dancers
learned to hang upside down
from the roof,
so they could fit
onto a packed car.
As a general rule,
any time you see a subway car
that isn't packed,
that means one of two things --
either it's 4:00 a.m.
on a Tuesday
or someone did
something unspeakable.
"Oh, look, honey.
This one's almost empt--
Oh, that smell. Oh, my God."
Now, there's no reason to panic.
In fact, as bad as things seem,
there are reasons for optimism.
China and South Korea have seen
slowdowns in new cases
and people in areas affected
by the outbreak
have been making the best
of the situation.
For example, in Wuhan, China,
the epicenter of the outbreak,
students
who had been on lockdown
were assigned homework
through an app
until they figured out a way
to get out of it.
In locked-down Wuhan,
teachers used an app
called DingTalk
to set up homework.
Kids realized if it got enough
one-star reviews,
it would be reviewed
from the app store.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thousands of reviews flooded in,
and DingTalk's rating fell
from 4.9 to 1.4 overnight.
That is amazing.
Although I will say,
although it is a bummer
for the people
who built that app.
I mean, you conceive of an app,
you develop it,
you go through rounds and rounds
of beta testing,
you finally have
a successful launch,
and then this brings it down.
"Hey, what happened to that app
of yours?"
"A bunch of dickhead kids
one-starred me."
"Well, you made a homework app,
so maybe you're the dickhead."
But, honestly,
maybe we should put these kids
in charge
of the coronavirus response.
Because while they
were out there,
coming up with ways
to shut down apps,
the most powerful man
in the world was visiting
CDC headquarters in Atlanta on
Friday in a hat and windbreaker
looking, not like a man steady
at the helm of a crisis,
but like a hung-over
little-league umpire.
Seriously, man,
what is this look?
You are inside.
Are you expecting
a thunderstorm?
[ As Trump ]
I heard there was a laboratory,
and as everyone knows,
laboratories run on lightning
because that's how
they invented Frankenstein."
[ Normal voice ] And as
countries across the world
were testing tens of thousands
of people a day
and taking extreme measures
to mitigate the outbreak,
our president was at the CDC
talking about
how he was getting
his information
not from doctors, but from his
favorite channel, Fox News.
-As of the time
I left the plane with you,
we had 240 cases,
or that's at least what was on
a very fine network
known as Fox News.
-Why are you getting
your information
about how many cases there are
from Fox News?
You're at the CDC.
You are surrounded -- You are
currently surrounded by doctors.
Just turn around
and ask one of them.
Doctor, give it to me straight.
Did you see me on Hannity
last night?
Was I good?
Kind of terrifying that in
the middle of a global pandemic,
Trump is getting his information
from Fox News
because at the same time Trump
is listening to Fox,
public health officials are
worried about making him angry
by telling him the truth.
For example, Politico reported
that public health groups
are hoping to convey
factual information to Americans
without antagonizing Trump.
They're afraid
of antagonizing Trump.
That is insane.
They're talking about
the president
the way a mailman
talks about a rottweiler
which makes sense
because Trump always looks
like he's about to bite
an intruder on the ass.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And you can tell
that the cult of personality
that insulates Trump
from dissent is having an impact
because Trump appointees keep
going out of their way
to compliment him in situations
where it's totally unnecessary,
from the health secretary
to the head of the CDC
to the surgeon general
just yesterday on CNN.
-Thank you, Mr. President,
for gathering your public health
experts here today
and for your strong leadership
in keeping America safe.
-I want to thank you
for your decisive leadership
in helping us
put public health first.
-We want to make sure folks
who are out there who at risk,
they're taking
extra precautions.
But speaking of being at risk,
the president,
he sleeps less than I do,
and he's healthier than I am.
-No, he's not. There's no way
he's healthier than you are.
I mean, look at him.
He doesn't even know
the difference
between inside and outside.
I'd expect him to bring
an umbrella,
but he doesn't know
how to use one.
Trump is desperately,
desperately trying to paint
a rosy picture to help
both his political fortunes
and the economy, which he sees
as crucial to his reelection.
For example, on Friday,
Trump actually admitted
that he wanted to keep people
trapped on a cruise ship
where passengers and crews were
diagnosed with coronavirus
rather than bringing them
onto the U.S. mainland
because it would increase
the number of coronavirus cases
in the U.S., and that would
make him look bad.
-I mean, frankly, uh,
if it were up to me,
I would be inclined to say
leave everybody on the ship
for a period of time
and use the ship as your base.
But a lot of people would rather
do it a different way.
They'd rather quarantine people.
And when they do that,
our numbers are going to
go up, okay?
Our numbers are going to go up.
They would like to have
the people come off.
I'd rather have the people stay.
But I go with them. I told them
to make the final decision.
I would rather
because I like the numbers
being where they are.
I don't need to have the numbers
double because of one ship.
-I'm sorry, but keeping people
trapped on a cruise ship
even if they don't have
coronavirus
should be
an impeachable offense,
because nothing good
ever happens on a cruise ship.
You never, never once have heard
a positive news story
about a cruise ship.
You'd never read the headline,
"Cruise Ship's Toilets
Work Great."
You have another reminder that
Trump is a lifelong scam artist
who is constantly running a con
and trying to B.S. his way
out of that con.
It's obvious he doesn't have
a plan for anything
other than his
own self-preservation.
For example,
there's been a major delay
in testing capacity
due to CDC errors,
which experts have called
a national disgrace.
Last week, the White House said
it would fail to meet its goal
in providing
enough coronavirus test kits
for 1 million people
by the end of the week,
and Vice President
Mike Pence said
they won't have enough tests
to meet demand.
Then, out of nowhere, during
a visit to the CDC on Friday,
Trump not only said
everyone could get a test,
he said the tests were perfect,
and for some reason,
compared them
to his infamous phone call
with the president of Ukraine,
you know, the one
that got him impeached.
-Anybody that wants a test
can get a test.
Anybody that needs a test
gets a test.
They're there.
They have the test.
And the tests are beautiful.
Anybody that needs a test
gets a test.
But anybody that needs a test
can have a test.
They're all set.
They have them out there.
And the tests are all perfect.
Like the letter was perfect.
The transcription was perfect.
-[ As Trump ] "Anyone who needs
a test gets the test."
[ Normal voice ]
"I need a test."
[ As Trump ] "Not you."
[ Normal voice ]
You're comparing the test
for a global pandemic
to the thing
that got you impeached.
That's not a good comparison.
That's like borrowing
your friend's Kia and saying,
"This reminds me a lot
of my last car,
the one I totaled after driving
it straight into a Wendy's."
What we're seeing now is
what happens
when a lifelong scam artist
has to manage
a major public health crisis.
Trump has always been able
to B.S. and threaten
and litigate his way
out of accountability
and avoid consequences.
And, now, as he oversees
the government's response
to a global
public health emergency,
he's trying to do
the same thing.
And it's worth remembering
that Trump's scams
didn't just include a fake
charity or a scam university.
He also ran
a scam health-care company.
-"The Daily Beast" reports today
on the vitamin-selling venture
launched in 2009 by a company
called The Trump Network.
It was a multilevel
marketing scheme
along the lines of Amway
or Mary Kay.
The scheme peddled
a number of diet products
and sham nutritional supplements
including a supposedly
customized vitamin regime
requiring users to send in
a urine sample
packed inside a very classy
special Trump-branded box.
According to Harvard doctor
and supplement expert
interviewed
by "The Daily Beast,"
the process is, quote, "a scam."
-For $140,
you can send in your urine
and get a tailored
version of vitamins,
none of which was proven
by science, by the way,
and they would be delivered to
you and you would pay, you know,
70 bucks a month, every month,
to increase your health.
-I'm sorry, but how do you
tailor vitamins for someone
based on their urine?
You don't want a cheek swab
or a blood sample?
That should be a red flag
right away.
That would be like if
you signed up for 23andMe,
and in order to give you
your family history,
they made you [bleep]
in a paper bag.
[ Laughter ]
So, that's the guy overseeing
the government's response
to a global pandemic
that threatens to overwhelm
the U.S. healthcare system.
And just as he lied
about his scam vitamin kits,
he's trying to lie
about the coronavirus outbreak.
Here he is on Friday
justifying his lies
by claiming he has
a natural ability
for dealing with
this kind of thing.
-You know, my uncle is
a great person.
He was at M.I.T.
He taught at M.I.T.
for, I think, like,
a record number of years.
He was a great super genius.
Dr. John Trump.
I like this stuff.
I really get it.
People are surprised
that I understand it.
Every one of these doctors said,
"How do you know so much
about this?"
Maybe I have a natural ability.
Maybe I should have done that
instead of running
for president.
-Yes. Yes, you should have.
[ Applause ]
You should have applied
to medical school,
and you should have
filmed the reactions
of the faculty
of that medical school
reading your application,
and you should have posted that
on TikTok and gotten
1 trillion views.
Seriously, you think instead of
running for President at age 70,
you should have become
a doctor instead?
The only white coat you should
be wearing is a straitjacket.
Also there is no way --
I'm sorry, but there is --
There is no way a doctor said
the words
"How do you know so much
about this stuff?"
I mean, maybe, maybe one of them
said it sarcastically, like,
you said, "I hear the
coronavirus will go away
when it gets less cloudy,"
and they said,
"Oh, man, how do you know
so much about this stuff?"
Also you think
you know about science
because your uncle was a doctor?
People don't
just automatically know
what their uncles know.
Otherwise, we would all know the
lyrics to every Steely Dan song.
This is what happens when
you put a lifelong con artist
and pathological liar
with zero intellectual curiosity
in charge of the government.
When an emergency comes along,
he doesn't care about
solving it, he just wants
to B.S. his way through it.
And now he's actively making
the situation worse.
The president is a deluded idiot
who thinks he's a...
-Super genius.
-This has been a closer look.
[ Cheers and applause ]